[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they say I'm a complicated man
I might take you down but I'll never let
you down you know bro I'll be out in an
hour
I don't think so running man you see the
van the central processing left about
five minutes ago and that won't be
another one for hours and hours by the
time you get downtown we're talking
overnight in the tombs and they
definitely want to rein your ass before
morning it's a shame we didn't get here
a little sooner you look depressed
Walton you're depressed
central los angeles place where drugs
crime and violence camp out what's going
on in the hood which I'll take a look at
that sign up there see what it says cash
for your home we know what that is what
it stands for it's called gentrification
that's what happens when the property
value of a certain area is brought down
listening yeah
they bring the property value down they
can buy the land at a lower price then
they move all the people out and raise
the property value and sell it at a
problem
[Music]
people feel the same people deal people
live in poverty where I live but this is
how it is it might be new to you but
it's been like this for years it's blood
sweat shields where they come down to
the [ __ ] I'm trying to they try so much
but they can't touch my inner mystery
when I try to show them they still can't
see I say is there arching my back the
son of my smile the right of my breasts
and the grace of my style I'm a woman
phenomenally Phenomenal Woman that's me
[Music]
just want to talk to my brother these
are my brothers
[Music]
about 5:30 p.m. to about 11:00 or so
that night I was banging that pretty
little wife many ways to fight battle
some people use their mind some people
use their fists what do you wanna do
college boy see I'm smart enough to know
it's not my game to play just a pawn
like everybody else used intelligently a
pawn can create a checkmate mr. Williams
or become a very powerful player himself
don't you understand this is all again
all of this like basketball and football
mr. big-time track star a game you play
it and you play to win because in the
real world no one wants to hear excuses
or empty rhetoric look down upon us with
forgiveness for all the sins we will
have in the future I know you understand
in the imperfect only for our Lord
[Music]
forget you saw your mom you got your
whole life
we're gonna like to
[Music]